-Our first guest tonight i
a Grammy Award-winning musicia
and member of the
Rock & Roll Hall of Fame
who you know from bands
such as Them Crooked Vultures,
Foo Fighters, and Nirvana.
His limited series,
"From Cradle to Stage,"
premieres today
with new episodes
streaming Thursdays
on Paramount+.
Let's take a look.
-♪♪ Bet you think
this song is about you ♪♪
♪♪ Don't you, don't you? ♪♪
-I don't know
if I did that right.
-That was awful!
[ Laughter ]
-It just really blew my --
And still to this day.
When I listen to music --
-So I can't understand, then
why you never
got as excited as I did
about Manhattan Transfer.
Because that's where
their genius is.
That they get -- that they d
four-, five-part harmony
in ways that is really har
to duplicate.
-I don't know,
but I used to get high
under that bridge over there
[ Laughter ]
-Please welcome to the sho
Dave Grohl.
It's so nice to see you, Dave.
-How you doing, Seth?
-I'm doing great.
This is really wonderful,
this docuseries, 'cause
this is based on a book
that your mom wrote.
She went out and interviewed
other musician's moms.
Was this an idea
she had on her own?
-Yeah, it was, actually.
So, my mother was a public
schoolteacher for 35 years
and when she retired, you know
I told her -- I'm like,
"Don't do that cruise-ship thing
that all retirees do."
I was like -- just --
I have a cruise ship.
I was like, "Jump on
the tour bus. Let's go."
And so I took her
around the world.
I took her to Australia
and Japan and all over Europe.
And in our travels,
she was like,
"Where are all
the other mothers?
Like, how come
other moms don't hang out
at their kids' rock shows, too?"
Which she always had.
I mean, she was the coolest mom.
Growing up,
she took me to jazz clubs,
and she always came
to punk-rock shows.
So she decided to go hunt down
all the other mothers,
and she made calls
to Dr. Dre's mother
and Pharrell's mother,
Miranda Lambert's mother,
and Geddy Lee's mother,
all these different moms,
and she interviewed them
and wrote a book called
"From Cradle to Stage,"
and in that book,
she realized that there were
these really clear parallels
in all of the relationship
between the mother
and the artist.
And then, after the book,
we were like,
"Well, let's turn it into
a documentary series."
-I mean, the mothers who -
the mothers of rock stars
or any musicians,
it's truly amazing
how supportive they have to be
Because even
if they loved music,
it's very likely
that their children
will make a kind of music
that is not the same
as what they loved growing up.
-Yeah.
-But you said your mom
came to early shows of yours
when it was maybe not --
-Oh, yeah. She was always there.
I mean, she, like --
You know, I think that --
that, as a parent,
you have to understand
and accept and appreciate
your child becoming
an individual, right?
And so, with musicians,
they usually decide
in between the ages
of, like, 11 and 13
that that's going to
become their identity.
You know. "I'm a musician.
You know?
So it's a parent's job
to, like, show them love
and then just
get out of the way.
Because that's
what their heart --
that's what their heart
lives for.
And so that's -- I'm sure --
You know,
my mom wasn't listening
to the Dead Kennedys
and Slayer with me every day
you know?
But she did appreciate
that, you know,
I was becoming my own person
And fortunately, she gave me
the freedom to do that.
-You -- You are someone
who strikes me
as the kind of person
who says yes
whenever an opportunity
presents itself.
One of the things you've
said yes to over the years
is being a musical guest
at "SNL"
sometimes with
very, very short notice.
-Yeah.
Well, I mean -- So I --
One of the great luxuries
of my life
is that I've had the honor
to play that show --
It's like 14 times
or something now.
And so -- But starting in 1992
So I got to see
all of these amazing casts
Like, I'm not sure
when I met you,
but I'm sure
it was 15 years ago.
You know?
-Yeah.
-So -- So being able, like
to be a part of the show
is something huge,
and the process is usually..
your manager
calls the publicist,
calls the show,
calls the record company,
and it's months and months
of preparation.
The last time
the Foo Fighters played,
Lorne called on Tuesday
and said,
"Hey, do you want to play
'Saturday Night Live'?"
And we said,
"Of course! When?"
And he said, "Saturday."
And so we literally, like,
loaded our guitars onto a plane,
flew out as fast as we could
Dave Chappelle was the host.
And it was great
to be back again.
But what made it really specia
was that Saturday,
that morning was the day
that they called the election,
and that -- that --
the -- the news
said that Biden
was the president.
So the -- the energy
in the studio was crazy.
-You did it once
with Mick Jagger.
You were the musical --
I'm sorry. You weren't
the musical guest.
You were Mick Jagger's band.
-Yeah.
That was funny
because that day I was --
I was literally sitting
on the toilet when Lorne called.
And I answered the phone
and I said, "Hello?"
It's like,
"Hold for Lorne Michaels."
I'm like, "Oh, my God."
And he's like, "Uh, David, uh,
just wanted to call and say --
He was saying that Mick
was going to be the host,
but he didn't have a band.
So he called and asked
if we would be his band.
And, you know,
of course we said --
I said, "Of course."
Like, we're going to be there.
And I looked at my schedule,
realized that we had a sho
that night.
I think it was in New Jersey
And so I said, "Okay.
I'll make that show go away.
Because there was no way
I was missing this opportunity
I called my manager.
He says, "You can't
make that show go away.
It's already sold out.
You're the headliner."
So we literally soundchecked
at 30 Rock
and then took a helicopter
to the gig,
played for 2 and a half hours,
took a helicopter back,
were Mick Jagger's backing ban
on the show,
and then we played
the after-party.
Do you remember the after-party?
-That was
a fantastic after-party.
-It was the greatest day
of my life! It was amazing
-That's crazy
that you were on the toile
when you got that call
because I remember
being on the other side.
Lorne called you
from the toilet, as well.
-Interesting. Well, that's
how these deals are made.
-Yeah, I remember
he came out of his bathroo
and said,
"Foo Fighters are in."
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know if you know.
We were actually FaceTiming.
I don't -- Did you --
-Oh. So you knew. You knew
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Do you remember
who was the host
the first time Nirvana
was on the show?
-First time Nirvana was on the
show, the host was Rob Morrow.
-Wow. And then the second time
-...who was from that show
"Northern Exposure."
-You guys were on with
Barkley once, right?
-Oh, Charles Barkley!
That's right!
And I remember --
Our bass player,
Krist Novoselic.
Krist Novoselic is 6'8."
Okay?
The bass player for Nirvan
is very tall.
And I remember when we wer
doing the promos that, you know,
on the Thursday before the show,
I remember seeing Krist
tower over Charles Barkley
and thinking, like, "Okay.
Now this is getting weird.
Like, now,
this is officially weird."
-Right. Well, it also
gives you a real appreciatio
for how hard Barkley worke
for those rebounds
when he's not even taller
than the tallest guy in Nirvana.
There was a long gap
between Barkley hosting.
He's done it quite
a few times recently.
But I remember him regaling us
with stories of the first time
he hosted and saying
that he was in his dressing room
when Nirvana was -- when you
guys were doing your songs
And he said, "I was sittin
there, and I was like,
'Are they saying "Rape me"?'
[ Laughter ]
-I do remember one of the
promos, his line was,
"Look, Ma. It's Nirvana."
And I was like, "Oh, okay.
-Hey, you guys --
In 2003, you did a show
with Christopher Walken,
and you realized
that was a great opportunity
because, being fans of the show,
you knew that meant
that he would introduce you,
this being the Foo Fighters.
-Yeah, you know, I mean,
everybody has their own
Christopher Walken
impersonation, and, of course,
we were huge fans
from everything, from, you know,
"The Deer Hunter"
to "Pulp Fiction."
Like, we just kind of
loved the guy.
And he came up to us befor
introducing us, and he said --
He said...
[As Walken] "The accent.
Is it on 'Foo' or 'Fighters'?"
And I knew if I said "Fighters,"
I knew what would happen.
And, so,
the house lights went down
and the camera hit him,
and he said...
[As Walken] "Ladies and
gentlemen, Foo FIGHTERS!"
And so that's how we referred --
We refer to ourselves
as Foo FIGHTERS,
you know, still to this day.
-Very, very impressive
that you saw that opportunit
and took it.
-Always thinking.
Always thinking.
-Hey, thanks so much.
So excited you're doing music.
And you also -- Real quick -
You have a documentary
that you directed.
Another thing that most
musicians have in common.
Not just parents who support
their music early on,
but life in a van.
And I'm certainly looking
forward to seeing that.
Because -- Do you miss -- Do you
miss your days in the band
Because I can think
it's probably a little bit
like your youth?
Like, you miss it but also
don't want to do it again.
-Well, you know, the great thing
about having that experience
is that you sort of
rely on that for --
you know, to keep
everything in perspective
for all the rewards and things
that come after.
But the cool thing about tha
documentary is that, you know,
I interviewed Ringo and Duff
and Slash from Guns N' Roses
and Steven Tyler
and Brian Johnson from AC/DC
all of these huge rock stars
but I also interviewed
some young bands,
a band called Starcrawler,
a band called Radkey.
And, you know,
what I realized is that, like,
the kids in Radkey
are having the same experience
that the Beatles had
when they were their age.
It's a 60-year difference,
but it all comes down
to that thing
that makes you
throw your life away
and just jump in a stinky va
with your friends.
So, yeah. I mean, do I miss it
Sometimes.
Do I -- Do I prefer, you know,
a nice G5 every once in a while?
Of course!
-Treat yourself.
Hey, thank you so much.
It's always a delight
to talk to you, Dave.
"From Cradle to Stage"
is available on Paramount+
And "What Drives Us"
is currently streaming
on The Coda Collection channel
exclusively on
Amazon Prime Video.